we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to go to our next caller
from the 6:02 area code caller from 602
who's this hello yeah you're on the air
who's this speak up please oh yeah I had
a question well why does Trump always
take um why does why does he always like
them you're there you're still with us
why is he always so light why did you
always bragging about the stock market
because he likes to brag I mean yeah I
know I'm I'm hearing that the stock
market is going down and what was he
gonna say then he has not talked about
it he just ignores it really yeah a
house I have another question all right
what's your other are Democrats still
talking about Russia which Democrats
it's like our people in general just
talking about Russia so there is that
over they're still talking about it
people do talk about Russia and what do
you think about it
which part the part about Putin
interfering with the election Putin
personally like them yeah I don't know
too much about Putin personally
interfering who do they say was
interfering I forgot I appreciate the
call thanks very much really really
appreciate it I stuck with it Pat you
know I did you know I did I did it I did
as best as I could there